so here's a shock you're not going to
believe this number one here from the
blaze it says following
the defund the police movement and the
abolish the police movement
constant negative coverage of law
enforcement by the media anti-police
sentiment become
becoming mainstream and the threat of
riots have contributed to a police
shortage across the country
the philadelphia police department
currently has 268 vacancies and is
expecting even more shortages in the
near future
neighboring new jersey is facing a
recruiting crisis according to pat
colligan
president of the new jersey state
policemen's benevolent association
uh colligan said that recent notorious
police-involved deaths of citizens such
as george floyd tamir rice and brianna
taylor have impacted recruiting efforts
colligan also said the quality has
really diminished in the last few years
you know in terms of the police officers
colonel patrick callahan said the
state's largest police agency received a
historically low number of applications
this year in some years
the new jersey state police would
usually receive between fifteen thousand
and twenty thousand
listen to this this year they've
received two thousand
qualified applications from fifteen to
twenty thousand
to two thousand in fact we have a local
news report here from
um philadelphia talking about their
situation was it which is
especially dire let's uh listen to that
local fop president john mcnesby says
it's kind of like a perfect storm
developing the eye of the storm
revolving around several issues
including
a dramatic rise in the number of
philadelphia police officers filing for
retirement
a diminishing pool of young people who
even want to be a big city cop
and the suspension of new officer
training because of the pandemic
under normal circumstances there would
be dozens of new recruits
coming in for training every three
months but the most recent class
graduated last december
and the next one isn't even expected to
begin until next month you got to
remember too that once you go into the
academy
takes you about 10 months to finish so
we're not looking at putting any boots
on the ground until maybe next spring
then you throw in the recent changes to
the department's residency
rules mandating all police trainees live
in philadelphia
before they enter the academy nobody's
going to move to philadelphia
hoping that they get a job they want to
make sure that they secure
employment and then move in richard
vonna director of the bucks county
police training center says
all of these issues are also inspiring
younger officers from the city
to seek employment in the suburbs and
not just from philadelphia
yeah you think
i mean the problem it's it's twofold
that they're you're gonna have a lot
fewer as we're hearing
applicants and right now we've only
talked about philly in new jersey this
is the case everywhere
um and the applicants you do have
are gonna get are gonna be worse
they're gonna have fewer fewer police
and
the ones that you have are gonna be
worse
in terms of of of quality and and their
you know qualifications and skill level
because i think a lot of
people who would make great police
officers and are highly qualified for it
they're going to say to themselves well
is there somewhere else where i can take
these skills maybe get into private
security
something like that
why would i want to take these skills
here
where even if i do my job correctly if i
if i follow the book to a t
my life could be destroyed
this is and you know republicans
to look at the political end of this
this is a problem that republicans could
be
trying to address could be speaking to
because it's a very very serious problem
and cities across the country are
dealing with the effects of it
and that's only going to get worse
because it turns out that yeah you you
despite what the abolish the police
idiots have to say
and of course the people you know the
the most prominent cheerleaders of that
movement
members of the squad and so forth uh
they're doing they're all well off
they're doing perfectly fine
they're in safe neighborhoods they've
they've got security they've got all
that kind of stuff
you know when they go to their job
they're surrounded by armed men
protecting them
but just the average people your average
american living in a city
um they're going to feel the effects of
that because it turns out you need
police officers
you do if you have laws
then you need people to enforce them
and right now the people who are making
the laws
are doing everything they can to
undermine and attack
the people tasked with enforcing the
laws that they made
just think about that for a second
it's the legislative branch of the
government
people in congress maxine waters and
every
all the other democrats who are the ones
leading the charge against the police
but they're also the ones making the
laws
that the police have to enforce
um so that's
you know that's that's what's gonna
happen you have more and more people say
of course
what's what's what's the point why why
do i want to get into this line of work
and republicans so republicans they
could be speaking to this
but instead you have republicans lining
up behind oh yeah we need police reform
that's what we need
now republicans talking about ending
qualified immunity
this is becoming a popular talking point
obviously on the left but even on the
rights
and so what does that mean you end
qualified immunity i'll tell you that
you get rid of qualified immunity and
you're just we're not gonna have any
cops
all the cops are leaving because what
what that means is that
every if you're a cop every person you
try to arrest
anyone you have to tackle to the ground
in the process of trying to arrest them
they can sue you now they can sue you
personally
every single person you encounter try to
arrest them
maybe you um you know you put the
handcuffs on it makes their wrists a
little sore now they can sue you they
can sue you personally
so if you want a recipe for having zero
cops that's the way to do it
and of course idiot republicans you know
they rather than
addressing that issue there yeah we need
police reform
no police reform is not what we need
right now that's not the problem
there's there's a lot of reform needed
in our cities and it's not to the police
first and foremost
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated